by Hollywood standards Robert Pattinson
has been around for what seems like a
lifetime already it's been 14 years
since Pattinson made his big-screen
debut and Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire and I've in a decade has passed
since he stole the hearts of tweens the
world over as the Twilight Saga is
brooding vampire Edward Cullen since
then Pattinson has carved out one of the
most intriguing careers in Hollywood by
continuing to claim challenging and
quirky roles and independent films when
it was announced that Pattinson was
returning to big franchise movies by
claiming the coveted lead in Warner
Brothers superhero flick the Batman the
Internet nearly imploded at the prospect
of Pattinson donning the cape to play
The Dark Knight while there were some
positive reactions many fans were quite
displeased at the casting news though hi
- for the - the point of Batman
he can be the am costume it turns out
that diehard bat fans weren't the only
ones miffed when that news broke in a
recent interview with variety Pattinson
said he was also pretty upset about the
news but for a totally different reason
he said when that thing leaked I was
furious
everyone was so upset everyone was
panicking from my team I sort of thought
that had blown up the whole thing it
seems that when Variety initially broke
the caste an exclusive the deal to bring
patents into Gotham was far from done in
fact the actor hadn't yet officially
auditioned for the role land talks with
Warner Brothers and the Batman director
Matt Reeves were still very much ongoing
the reason Pattinson was so upset was
because he really wanted the parts and
was afraid all the premature chatter
from the internet fandom might actually
scare Warner Brothers away from casting
him on the day the Batman news broke
Pattinson found himself compulsively
googling his own name for news about the
expected fall outs luckily Warner
Brothers eventually stood up for its
casting decision regarding the Batman
confirming Pattinson would indeed
portray the Caped Crusader and Reeves
his upcoming film ironically even after
flipping out about someone else leaking
his involvement with the Batman before
it was a done deal
Pattinson himself accidentally let a
spoiler slip for another hotly
anticipated Warner Brothers movie
Todd Phillips's Joker during his chat
with variety Pattinson was said to have
made a mundane comment about Joker star
Joaquin Phoenix before asking to retract
it as it apparently spoiled something in
the film even if it was relatively minor
the actor admitted that he's not used to
thinking about spoilers during
interviews he said oh I
definitely should not say that I'm so
used to pretty arthouse movies where you
can watch the movie three times and
still not know what it's about
Pattinson might just be an inspired
casting choice who could be more than
capable of bringing pathos and
physicality to one of the most
complicated superheroes ever created if
you don't believe that look past patents
since twilight years and seek out some
of the indie gems he's been cranking out
of late particularly the sci-fi flick
highlight Reeves and company have yet to
announce any more casting for the Batman
which is not yet begun filming it's
slated to hit theaters in June 2021 so
we've got a bit of a wait ahead to see
what Pattinson brings to the complex
dual roles of Bruce Wayne and Batman
here's hoping he delivers the goods when
the Batman finally swings into action in
a couple of years but fear not teen
Pattinson the actors chiseled features
will be more than visible on big screens
in the intervening years with Robert
Eggers the lighthouse on the immediate
horizon and David me showed 'he's the
king hitting netflix soon after
Pattinson is also hard at work shooting
Christopher Nolan's Tennant this very
moment with that film scheduled to hit
theaters next year it's weird I'm quite
glad I'm doing Christmas movie right now
cuz I've got something else to be
nervous about
2020 will also see Pattinson appear in
the anxiously awaited adaptation of
Donald ray Pollux beloved novel the
devil all the time check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite actors
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you